for kids in different car the travel
plans change everything's completely
different yeah I feel like Adam might
feel like he dodged a bullet at the end
of at the end of season 1 Oh yep every
day how would that play this season 2
season 2 is more the same really yeah I
mean I think we were starting to really
find our groove in the first season and
season 2 maybe a little more edgy a
little more opinionated Adam becomes and
it's just you know the kids are growing
and getting a little more brave and just
kind of that that sort of parenting
thing you know the mean and kind of the
day to day war that you fight as parents
against the little ones that you
ultimately lose you know as an as an EP
of this show and overseeing things
obviously having been a part of a really
successful franchise you know what it
takes to get there you know you know
from your mouth to God's ears right yeah
there's a lot of moving parts to a TV
show there's you know you do the best
you can you have you write the jokes as
best you can you tell the most
interesting stories you can you push the
actors to find the funniest takes that
you can you but there's also you know
the moving part that is the landscape of
television these days which is
ultimately forever changing so you know
the network and where what your time
slot is what the competition is what the
numbers are I mean is that's a whole
shifting sands game so who knows no
ahead is hard to find these days why was
this the right show though I mean I
received in it yeah for me it just felt
like it was time to make that next step
and you know I'm a dad in real life and
it's been a lot of funny things have
happened and
I think I wanted to sort of tell some of
those kinds of stories and it's been fun
I've never played a guy in a
relationship before so it's been fun to
explore that end of it and as well as
being a dad and and just the sacrifices
that you make as parents that I've you
know personally witnessed mm-hmm
actually last time we spoke I know we
were talking about your daughter and at
the time I think it was her birthday and
you were too in she was saying she
wanted Rihanna yeah had her birthday did
you get her either they couldn't pull it
off as difficulties getting Elvis
probably hopefully it has her musical
tastes changed it off you know still her
favorite you know really she likes she's
into it let's see Lady Gaga Rihanna
tariffed the same kind of stuff yeah
singing away she's into she's riding
horses now so that's inexpensive
has she I don't I know that terrain I
can't even imagine that's the one thing
you're like really horses yeah how about
the flute
how about soccer yeah you know being a
parent what's it like juggling you know
juggling work life and has she expressed
interest I mean there's kids on the show
there she come to set is she interested
in this kind of thing she's been to the
set yeah she it's not really her thing I
don't think she's more of a she's more
into music good stuff I think she'd
probably love to do that if if she got
the opportunity um schedule is tricky I
mean as far as as far as an active
schedule goes a sitcom schedule is
pretty it was about the most user
friendly there are annoying you rehearse
all week and then you have one
late-night Friday nights but you have a
late call and this doesn't go to too
late I'm usually home by 9:30 10 o'clock
on a Friday night so that's the one late
night but the rest of time I'm kind of
home when she gets home from school so
heat meals together and stuff so it's
it's pretty user friendly a
single-camera like a drama or something
like that you know you're working 14 16
hour days every day and those are
exhausting but this is if you want to
have a family that sitcom is the way to
go and I love a sitcom
you know the in being in front of the
live audience you know it's a great
sounding board for the jokes because
it's hey if they're not laughing it's
probably not funny
do you rework things sometimes different
in you asleep in constantly if the joke
doesn't score it'll be a different joke
second pass yeah that's kind of the
luxury that you have with a live
audience you can use them as a sounding
board what about the cast you've
surrounded yourself with I mean
obviously you know from watching the
show the chemistry's really good and I
mean almost seems you are you I the
married couples actually really
believable yeah Eliza's fantastic she
really is she knows her way around a
joke she said well she's a solid actors
to begin with I mean really really
talented there she is look at that and
and who else Kevin Nealon is really
funny and really hard to keep a straight
face with him and then we have stacy
keach as a regular this year which is
really great I mean he's you know he's
like an icon so it's fun to have someone
of that caliber onstage all the time you
know you kind of when you're across from
him you're kind of thinking okay bring
me a game don't goofing around that it's
got to be good and it's fun and the kids
are all really great they're talented
and it's the cool even plays Kevin's
wife is fantastic I think she's super
inventive I think we have a really good
group and Matt Cooke is just bizarrely
funny this is the choices he makes now
listen about the table we don't go Wow
I'd never would have seen that coming
you know there's some just some of the
ways he delivers the lines is really I
think they were a really good group I'm
proud of them
how is your how do you celebrate your
50th I know you just had it your 50th I
had had a little small party at my house
yeah and I didn't I paced myself well
which I'm notorious for not doing at the
party at the house but yeah had a good
time friends and my losses from this
perspective kind of changed you look at
things in it we appreciate them in a
different way
you know it's funny I think as I hit 50
I kind of thought now it's time to sort
of slow down a little bit and kind of
you know stop and smell the roses a
little more and I'm kind of busy er than
I've ever been you know when they have
sitcom schedules three weeks on one week
off and so we can stay out ahead of the
writers with production and I'm doing
also top gear at the same time and
that's traveling all over the world so I
mean since we started this this season
have been to Norway France Italy
Northern California I just got back from
Vegas this last week Wow go to Utah next
week or something that's it's it's crazy
and you're shooting the UK a lot so I'm
flying around alone
so today it's a little tiring but my
point is at 50 right right right
that is rude
[Laughter]
he's just working with accent so yeah so
so it's it's it's just busy busier than
I thought I was gonna be when they hit
50 but it's good you conditioned I think
as an actor all these years of doing it
like if you get a gig you take it you
know say no because you never know when
the next one is and so you just I guess
I over yest and Here I am with a plate
so but it's fun I really enjoyed doing
both and they're both really fun I think
that puts their comment into context you
I write in an interview where you're
like they asked about retirement you're
like yeah I sit back and no not a thing
yeah and I'm sure when you're that busy
you think about that sometimes you know
it's a double-edged sword isn't it you
think when you're working a lot of me
probably experienced this when you're
working like you do like a month-long
stint and you're like gosh I can't work
every weekend this month and they can't
get it break and I want nothing to do
and then a month goes by or you got
enough any like wow what's going on you
know so you kind of you always want what
you can't have the grass is always
greener so then but it's you know it's
fun I feel really fortunate and I'm
happy to get a group of people here and
the other show on top care that's a
great group of people there and yeah
feel really lucky